[Musik]
das tauwetter zwischen den beiden
staaten ist von beiden seiten schon
ehrlich gemeint das kann man schon sagen
frage ist nur welche interessen stehen
dahinter also die nordkoreaner haben ein
klares interesse nachdem sie jetzt
atommacht geworden sind und dass auch er
doch relativ eindrucksvoll gezeigt haben
jetzt die wirtschaft wieder auf
vordermann zu bringen wären durch
nordkorea gereist ist sieht dass es
außerhalb der hauptstadt pjöngjang
wirklich wirtschaftlich im argen liegt
kommt teilweise kommt kein wasser mehr
aus dem wasserhahn die infrastruktur ist
kaputt obwohl nordkorea das reichere
land war es geht also jetzt darum dass
die sanktionen gelockert werden
darauf hofft kinder um und südkoreas
präsident nun hofft dass er wieder
spieler in diesem spiel wird denn im
letzten jahr wir erinnern uns haben sich
kindern und donald trump vor allen
dingen ein kleinbürger rhetorisch damit
zu nach dem anderen geliefert dürfen
nicht vergessen die hauptstadt südkoreas
ist immer bedroht auch durch die
konventionellen waffen nordkoreas also
nicht nur durch die atomwaffen
das treffen zwischen dem südkoreanischen
und dem nordkoreanischen machthaber soll
den boden bereiten jetzt für die für das
weitere treffen im mai oder juni
zwischen donald trump und kim jong-un
amerikaner wollen ein bekenntnis zur
denuklearisierung nordkoreas und das
bekenntnis hat amerika tun bekommen
ich glaube allerdings nicht dass
nordkorea hat letztlich seine atomwaffen
aus der hand geben wird
[Musik]